the three is always very difficult  someone always gets left out and that's  very much the case in this but from  Abigail's point of view she's just  trying to survive was always thought she  has no choice I'm on my side always  she's continually faced with if I want  to get back to where I began my life as  a lady almost despite her character she  has to continually choose sort of who  was some always things to do I wouldn't  know who to compare it to her or what to  compare it to I just loved her kind of  the way she unfolds  not quite following I apologize for dish  I'm thinking well she's that yeah she's  the baddie I think and those big blue  eyes and she's sweetness and light and  the poor hard on my girl she totally  manipulates everything she gets Sarah  out she pretends to love the Queen the  Queen thinks it's all real but it's not  it's awful I wouldn't say she's  manipulative I would just issues she's  smart that would  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]